you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
right now and I just got paired up
playing a 3-2 game okay let's see how
this plays I don't let's go into a well
to be determined all right let's go with
d5 and hmm I'm gonna take right away mr.
bishops gonna be coming out to g2 and
before developing my bishop I'm gonna
play c5 so let's see I'm doing this by
the way oh I get to play my knight to c6
okay so I played my pawn up to c5 prior
to moving my bishop because in the event
of captures on this square I can just
recapture in one move okay so my knight
is pinned hmm and if I'm not careful
Knight to e5 so ship d7 hmm robot just
capturing here pawn takes there might
even be Knight takes I have to be
careful of either Knight most so let's
see Bishop d7 I'm considering hmm
Bishop d7 and then what hmm let's think
here of course Bishop d7 Queen takes e5
pawn takes Bishop takes I think this
should be fine let me break the pen my
Rilke played a c8 it's one of these I'm
not so enthusiastic about Bishop d7 but
you know what where else is he gonna go
I don't I don't think preparing
something keto is a good idea so let's
take here I have to recapture and now I
think everything should be fine right
here
rook c8 you know I I'd really like to
exchange light square bishop so I'd be
happy to see Knight takes Knight Bishop
takes
and I think I think the worst has passed
here just premium of that so this this
is already pretty good here for for
black pretty happy about this okay my
Knights pinned or excuse me my rook is
pinned my opponent a7 is hit my first
thought was a six but you know what
let's develop and defend and this
there's really not a better square for
my bishop anyhow you know let's go here
there's rook d8 but I'm not
inconvenienced I'll be out of this pin
soon enough once I Castle Queen c7 on
rook d1 or maybe I should think a bit
more forward let's castle these Knights
are offset my knight is pinned I don't
like this
hmm I'm thinking about h6 but what about
Queen d4 let's go with Queen d4 yeah
that should be fine there might be
Bishop takes Knight and I could even
consider taking it upon on Queen takes
Bishop 94
there's Queen e7 and this heavy piece
ending I still kind of like my position
um big moment here I think at least I
might want to go into a Brooke ending
where I have a slightly better rook rook
position and I'll have a flight square
with pond takes although I'm upon takes
bishop probably just avoiding the Queen
exchange is what I would do I'm gonna go
in for this yeah so on 94 I'll play I
think Queen f5 or e5 or maybe even take
on b2 let's work this out a little bit
time to calculate Queen takes b2 Knight
takes Bishop Queen the knight takes
Bishop rook takes Knight Queen takes a 7
I feel like just playing it a little bit
more simple
Queen d4 I know let's make a move let's
go here Knight takes is possible because
it's defending the Queen so I'll do this
and I still have a a seven covered I
need a flight square yeah so and of the
two flight squares
maybe h5 because then there's the idea
of h4 and he could be a giant thorn it's
not yet a threat hmm
it's an interesting imbalance I think I
could cover all my base I'm gonna I'm
gonna shoot for this let's see if I
could uh yeah let's try this imbalance I
could have played it just a lot simpler
but I'm gonna shoot for this let's play
first this move I think I could
eventually coordinate my rooks and I'll
be playing out for the increment soon so
let's start with this if the Queen side
pawns are all exchanged I'll have no
issues so I have good coordination well
not just yet my books aren't coordinated
but this should be good for me and how
to track that pond down let's start with
this just so there's no Queen a3 to hit
my rook so Queen here there's not a way
to attack my rook and defend the pond
this is three two just double-checking
there for a second I need a flight
square let's get that guy in and yeah
okay so as mentioned if these guys are
exchanged I could even think about this
but with my time situation well that's
not let's go here first and they're
allowing this
maybe I should have played h5 first I'm
going to look to do this next yeah let's
get that guy in so incoming rook to be
to I want to do this soon my rooks are
not attacked just gotta watch out for
that and actually let's do this stopping
h5 first I could even think about rook
f5 this should be winning for me
there's no Forks I mean there's this
move so now they have to tend to f2 and
this is convenient because I will be
defending let me get out of this I'll be
defending f7 soon so Queen f6 I just
take they'll be a one King and pawn
ending so let's take here and give some
more checks actually I want to pick up
this pawn and keep the structure as is
it's close to mate no I know let's give
another check and let's just take here
so now there's a diagonal open but I
should be able to cover everything this
rook is a monster right here let's keep
pushing him six seconds let's get behind
him and keep pushing away rook here
there's no Queen check Queen move with
check I should say oh I just dropped
that pun I missed that
this is gonna be perpetual now ah that
stinks okay I still have this man no
perpetual please no perpetual that's
going to be perpetual let's see just
don't get made it whatever happens don't
get mated
I block with this rook there is this
pawn push but I want to get a queen I
definitely want to get a queen okay here
I think and I have this move mmm
terrible technique I dropped em seven I
should have never dropped def seven
let's make sure we don't lose on time
that pond you just allow so many
different checks like this let's go here
mm-hmm this is tricky let's go here
first I think this was uh no I'm not
threatening this check okay this should
be good because with the King here the
the checks are a bit more limited have
this and there's not a good check now I
get to block hmm tricky this game should
have been over it's not easy to dodge
these checks
don't fall for me my king sneaking out
he might be sneaking out now might oh my
goodness
go here I guess just clean check here
and then to these two squares yeah I bet
you the computer will definitely have
this as a draw but can my opponent find
the draw I think they did that was the
last key move they're playing off of the
increment here let's do this they're
gonna go back I'll just sneak that one
in there oh they just won on time
ah I lost in time there oh that's
terrible
okay well
that's gonna happen let's see that that
must have been a perpetual with these
Queen moves but ah what can you do
alright well we're gonna go over it with
stockfish I was interesting with the
whatchamacallit
in the the middle game I think I got out
of the opening like pretty good but
we'll double-check see where we can both
improve okay let's see what stockfish
has to say on this one so this is a
Catalan territory and as mentioned this
c5 prior to Bishop to e7 is in the event
of a capture for when the Queen is off
of the D file in the event of the
capture I can recapture in just one move
not too big of a deal but just anyhow
that was my thought process on that one
I get knight c6 in I'm already feeling
pretty comfortable it is suggesting
Bishop d7 okay I probably should have
come up with that a little bit quicker
as you know he's it's too weakening to
try to go about development by way of b6
and Bishop to b7 this Bishop already on
the diagonal it's too much too difficult
to get that in so Queen takes there was
also I think it popped up D takes yeah
so either one on D takes I'm just
recapturing and on clean c4 this is
probably where I would have spent a lot
of time suggesting Bishop to e7 had a
little bit of time to think I don't know
that I would have come up with that I'm
thinking more along the lines of
developing my queen although Queen b6
Knight c3 and then I have to worry of
night a4 to drop all the way back to e7
okay now Bishop b6 okay just to give a
feel for that other Smoove sequence
taking on c5 first I'm feeling pretty
comfortable right now Knight to e5
mmm okay nothing wrong with rook c8 it's
most natural just developing and yeah
this is where I felt I was already equal
and the computer thinks so
a six it's my first thought Bishop c5
that's fine
the castles Bishop their queen d4 have I
played Bishop takes I have to considered
pawn takes it does it's fine with this I
was worried of a cool avoiding the Queen
exchange yeah taking like this superior
minor peace ending likes black here
monster Bishop on d4 pressure on b2 and
I already have my flight square so we
went for this I went for that instead
Queen takes B - yeah Queen takes B -
Knight takes rook takes Queen takes
hitting my rook pressure on b7 rook b5
yeah okay it's still pretty even ish
let's go back so Queen there Knight
takes Queen takes and then yeah it's
pretty even and could have played it to
lots well no you know what I was
thinking I had a choice here
not so much I pretty much had to go and
had to go in for this imbalance as
otherwise there's no compensation for
having my pawn structure split
I'm just moving out of the way takes
pawn takes there's no no reason to do
that to my Queen side structure so this
is fine I'm looking to liquidate the
Queen side as mentioned I was able to do
that and I wonder if it would have
suggested right around here the move b3
it does suggest b3 I didn't have time to
calculate it though tried to play
practically this should still be
something yeah still an advantage what
would have been the continuation I'm
just
curious here b6 is probably something a
bit elaborate you know cuz this Queen
gets here how am I getting behind here
it's a little bit tricky or maybe not I
guess the idea is still rook to d8 and
doubling on this second rank mmm
easier to calculate liquidate the Queen
side stay on the second rank I think my
opponent needed to constantly keep my
rook in check keep him under attack and
not allow me an opportunity to double on
the second rank Queen a5 is being
pointed out constantly keeping pressure
I think will be the name of the game and
this ending I think this is a useful
point to be made aware of if I'm if I'm
allowed to double the rooks I'm the
second rank it's just not good for white
because I will be crashing through like
in the game on the f2 square so
constantly keeping pressure on the rook
is the name of the game here started
right with Queen c3 their Queen c7 is
being suggested my first thought was one
of these two to attack the rook but
what's being pointed out is Queen c7 not
even allowing any of these three moves I
can't get that other rook working but
the one opportunity I had to get the
rook activated and d8 or bieed in that
case and then Queen there I was thinking
this move is an idea but I guess I'm not
having any perpetual or white wouldn't
have any perpetual there's a check but
now not an ensuing check on this
diagonal it would be a different story
if let's say I don't know let's say if
this pawn was here and I don't know
let's just say there's a nothing move
first and the Queen was on this square
still it's okay I was thinking this is a
different story but I always have this
f5 move it's always something to be
aware of this clamping down h5 move it
makes the perpetual check for white that
much more likely
so that's why I was during the game
saying you know what if I have an
opportunity to play h5 I want to do that
and I did in this case because now it's
much different I get this structure in
and I was just going to say it's a lot
easier to cover f7 well in the game I
ended up dropping f7 but hopefully get
the idea here this is a much more it's a
much more harmonious structure it's an
ad it's an adequate home for the black
king and it does well to prevent
perpetual checks okay I think I said
that right okay so we got the rooks
doubled eventually and yeah okay well
this is winning for black but
unfortunately I dropped off seven and
allowed perpetual and then ultimately
lost on time so if I didn't drop f7 as
you see plus 10 minus or minus 10 minus
5 stuff yeah rook h6
oh the I shouldn't have even allowed
this stuff mmm that was it's a double
attack against my rook and pawn
yeah and now it is in fact a draw I
shouldn't have even allowed this so a
better move at this point just to be
super cautious should have been to get
all of my pieces first defended if I
could if I could do it over I would
first do this move because now I've
acquired a position where absolutely
everything is defended if the Queen
moves I play here there's the follow-up
of then let's just make some move rook
here and then rook here and I could even
give up my rook for example let's say
King here broke here Queen back I could
push and allow this threatening this
next but didn't have time to think it
through but interesting game at least we
got to see these this imbalance tending
the two rooks versus the Queen and we
see how we could completely of course
lose track of time
this was I guess another opportunity
where I could have one not gonna go into
it is probably a little bit elaborate
rook to a five I'm now thinking it moves
like that I'm trying to keep all my
rooks really close to my king to allow
for these blocks with their blocking
checks and such but interesting game
interesting imbalance here the two
Brooks versus the Queen name of the game
is to try and stay coordinated allowed
this perpetual and then lost on time
here but hopefully as usual you got
something out this video and feel free
to leave any comments in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next one that's all for now take care
bye
you